avec moi sur le plateau denise
bombardier auteurs vraiment bardier re
bonsoir vous les avez suivi vous avez
suivi presque une année de cette tournée
absolument pas ce que j'ai fait ah oui
pour faire le livre sur le lien avec
céline vous avez côtoyé bien joué mais
j'ai dit l'énigmatique silencio mais il
faut dire aussi le mystérieux
rennes-angers et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire et c'est pour ça qu'il
avait tant de enfin c'était un homme
très séduisant le charme
oui j'avais dire de la séduction parce
qu'ils étaient mystérieux peut-être
parce que moi aussi j'aime les hommes
mystérieux mais c'était vraiment un
homme mystérieux ce qui était ce qui
était aussi renversant chez lui c'est
qu'il avait une sorte de fraîcheur
devant les succès qui lui arrivait c'est
il était toujours étonné de voir que les
que les succès arriver mais enfin il y
avait tellement de volonté et de
puissance parce que c'était un homme
puissant moi qui a été renouvellé jamais
froid
ah non c'était impossible mais les gens
avaient peur de lui parce que de toute
façon il faut dire une chose que céline
et rené c'était que c'est la course et
comme la cour de louis xiv avec les
courtisans promis le premier cercle le
deuxième cercle le troisième set qu'il
dit un oui est ce que tu as par la rue
ni bouger par la renier hier et mais lui
n'en jouait pas et c'était impossible
qu'il n'en qu'ils soient du qu'il soit
du goût de ça il le savait mais il ne
jouait absolument pas de sa société il
établissait les frontières sont si
claires ou l'audi fidèles pour sa
famille sa grande joie mais aussi
professionnels redoutable pour ceux qui
se mettaient en travers de son chemin
certains l'ont bien su père marchand il
faut quand même souligner que c'est
incroyable ce qu'il a accompli là tout
misé on le disait sur céline dion et le
succès phénoménal
ça prend un homme de chiny oui pour
connaître les rouages du show-business
emprunte sa prévision ça prend un timing
et son papa le décider dans la vie
moi je dis moi dix mots déjà dit parce
qu on ait changé beaucoup j'ai eu la
chance de faire quatre ou cinq projets
avec lui et céline et rené minimiser
m'avait dit récemment dans les trois
dernières années 4 dernières années
j'aurais pas pu avec l'industrie de la
musique aujourd'hui faire ce que j'ai
fait avec c'est le bon timing était
parfait et donc il s'est servi d'une
industrie grandissante avec le cd il se
servit de l'egypte assez négativement
bien au contraire de façon très
intelligente ici servi même le musée
plus une époque on faisait peut citer le
laboratoire hra musique au québec celle
à 9,4 spéciaux pour musique avec
musiques russes pour lancer ses nouveaux
albums s'est servi de son nez pour
lancer la carrière internationale et
puis je me mens la leçon que j'avais
pris avec rené parce qu'on avait
beaucoup de chevaux je me suis par le
business a créé quelque chose qui
m'intéressait et venez me mets toujours
dit je leur fait gagner des sous d'abord
ils vont avec fille délabré et c'est ce
que fait toute sa carrière dont il s'est
assuré que son amie fazae soit avec
céline avant lui d'aborder aux exigences
financières et il n'avait pas de
complexe face à ces grosses machines
vous parlez de sony face aux européennes
aux plus face aux français il savait
qu'il avait en mai un talent brut
je pouvais aller partout sur la planète
mais ils savaient qu'ils étaient faux
pas quand même pas s'imaginer que il se
voyait avec des failles et c'était un
homme qui était toujours dans l'action
mais et surtout bien nous aussi mais
vous avez dû le constater c'est que il
savait ce que les gens aimaient et en ce
sens là ce n'était pas quelqu'un je
comprends que la musique d'aujourd'hui
ne l'intéressait pas ne l'intéressait
pas parce que c'était pas ça il voulait
faire le il voulait rejouer le plus
grand nombre de gens possible s'excusait
ce que donnait le disais c'est tellement
intéressant lorsque rené m'avait dit au
début de 47 jusqu'au matin montée c'est
de nos débuts de sa portée face l isi
elle faisait des spectacles avec
chansons gaies
tant dans les festivals il n'était pas
le bon public
n'hésitez pas grave il dit je voulais
que les gens qui aient vu céline ne sais
pas si dieu se distingueront chanteuse
donc tout était axé sur la voie la
grande chanteuse qui était pour un jour
arriver à battre cette marque chanteuse
beaucoup d'analogies avec le jeu
évidemment pour une raison évidente il
aimait jouer c'est un joueur mais il n'a
rien laissé au hasard dans ce plan de
match vous avez hissé lundi lyon chaque
geste était calculé il n'y a pas eu de
tête d'éléphant de chance mais c'était
programmé c'est à dire que se servaient
des éléments qui l'entouraient pour
bâtir comme un jeu d'échecs qui a su
bluffer aussi à mes yeux c'est que
c'était un bluffeur c'était blaffer mais
un bluffeur d' de tels talents qu'il
confondait les gens autour de lui
c'était pas évident qu'ils étaient rené
angélil quand tu y arrives à new york
devant sony mais il leur donnait à
penser qu'ils avaient intérêt à être à
ceux ci à lui donc c'est ils réussissent
elles étaient très charmeur une ouïe
très charmant pas d'un sens de charme et
sonne pas la fin mais charmante jamais
totalement oui eh bien j'ai fait partie
des gens quand tombe sous le charme de
rennes il est vrai que la planète
oui voilà mais il y avait quand même le
cheval de course qui t'apprennent
sourire toujours que c'est ça qu'il faut
jamais oublier
et il faisait peur aussi bon là vous
avez du talent il y avait le cercle
était comme louis devant la cour ce qui
n'est même pas au suc avait déjà
critiqué rosicky les tikis et l'indien
il lui il leur en voulait pour le réseau
mais pas seulement ça c'est que il y
avait des bd au fond il y avait des murs
des barrières et il ya des gens qui ne
pénétrait pas je serai au cercle le plus
près enfin à part leur septième mais et
c'est elle il y avait des connes y avait
des non-dits et quelqu'un qui était pas
intelligent il durait pas longtemps avec
lui parce qu'il parce qu'il dépassait
les dépasser ses désirs à lui et ses
exigences à lui et à ce moment là je
pour être éjecté mais quand ils sont
intelligents et qui comprenait vous dire
que si s'il fallait avancer jusque là il
avançait pas plus loin que la c5 et tout
le monde et ça ça moi aussi c'était
impressionnant c'est que il sentait le
talent de quelqu'un et quand il parle à
quelques il savait ce que cette personne
là était capable de faire et ce qu'elle
ne pouvait pas faire des fouilles à
porter finale mais il avait donc une
perception très très très très fine des
hommes
c'est une grande tristesse pour la
famille bien sûr ils s'étaient préparés
mais qu on le sait quand ça arrive c'est
un drame
céline dion devra c'était un peu comme
ans il avait passé la main mais quand
même il est encore là il y aura un autre
céline dion ne devra vivre sans son
homme participe moins très
personnellement c'est pas le jour où il
meurt qu'il faut se mettre à parler de
sa monnaie parce que là on peut imaginer
que le désarroi de ces lignes dans
lequel elle est dans le désarroi en même
temps là deux petits enfants là et là
toute la machine elle à la terre entière
qui l'attend elle doit affronter ça et
elle va affronter ça parce qu'elle va le
faire pour lui et ça je suis sûr qu'elle
va elle est habitée par lui mais pour le
moment on peut pas évidemment c'est une
très bonne question mais bien habité par
lui c'est bien dit pierre marchand je
vous me rappeliez l'anecdote que vous
n'aurez publié tout à l'heure il est il
nous avait fait entendre un album c'est
à dire que chaque album parce que à
l'époque de musiqueplus partir des
années 80 ans et céline il avait adopté
une motion pour me dit que vous n'êtes
plus à l'époque c'était le nouveau truc
créé là et céline par sept sa période
chanter devant le pape
donc vraiment pas branché pour les gens
qui écoutaient musiqueplus et russell la
mener tranquillement vers musiqueplus et
et avec et sap sap a été forcée moi je
travaillais moi j'aimais bien céline je
trouvais
quelque chose de spécial il lui était
immense émoi vendeurs donc on a commencé
à travailler chaque album avait une
émission spéciale qui est une émission
de lancement sont souviens même le
quorum en europe c'est la première fois
qu'ils lui a tenu la main sont embrassés
ses lacs ses sorties le fait qu'ils
soient qu'ils étaient amoureux de
chevaux et rené avait développé avec moi
par hasard une fois j'espère buts et
l'album avant tout le monde à faire à
part les gens de cbs à l'époque donc
j'écoute l'album sa voiture il s'adonne
immense succès il me rappelle au
prochain album a vraiment dit il faut
faire la même chose pour faire quoi
il n'hésite venir dans ma voiture on se
mettait dans un dans un stationnement
public et on y est je me suis quand même
obligé un rite est il réel effet pendant
des heures jusqu'au jour où une une
parce que même j'étais je suis et céline
est un spectacle aussi pour l'ancien
forum et il ne faudra que dans sa
voiture son immense mercedes
on était dans le garage et cela n'était
pour monter dans une ue il voulait
prendre le temps que j'écoute l'album
voiture devant le forum dans le fait ça
je compte encore que physiquement plus
fort que je prête ensemble mais les mois
dit je t'envoie quelqu'un qui te le fais
écouter il était super eagles il vous
faut pas dire non je prédis est en
marche
c'est vraiment bon des anecdotes denise
bombardier merci infiniment à bientôt
lancé